hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game that was played in 1934
between uh the leading Peruvian player
of that time Esteban canal and an
unknown player by the name of jorvata it
was played in a simultaneous exhibition
it was played in Hungary like I said
1934 and even though uh his best years
uh you know Festival Canal when he was
playing chess were arranging from 1920
to 1930 this is uh from 1934 and it's
from a simultaneous exhibition and
usually the best games are from
simultaneous exhibitions as a very
strong player will face a lot of weaker
players and then good things will of
course happen for the viewers now uh the
reason why I stumbled upon this game
even though I have seen it a long long
time ago is that I was uh if you've seen
my video on the game that I played in
the Croatian chess League uh I had no
idea what my opponent was going to play
and I didn't really prepare so I was
just uh you know checking up sometimes I
was interested what if he played E4
should I play the Scandinavian and then
uh this game popped up out of nowhere
and I was so happy that I that I saw it
before the game as it really lifted my
spirit so it's only 14 moves and you
will really be able to punish someone if
they do this too and if you face the
Scandinavian defense a lot so let's
check it out Esteban Canal had the white
pieces and he opened with Ponte E4 now
interestingly Esteban Canal uh as strong
as he was even defeated world champion
Max either in a tournament in Venice
that was played in 1948 but that is not
his most famous game this is his most
famous game so E4 with D5 the
Scandinavian defense he captures on D5
Queen captures and now Knight to C3 so
okay we've seen this uh Many Many Times
Standard ideas are queen to d8 queen to
A5 and of course my favorite Queen to D6
if you are interested in how to play
this I also made a tutorial on it will
be the first link in the description
below if you want to check out some
lines but here we have Queen to A5 uh
still called the main line and now Pawn
to D4 with upon the C6 and Knight to F3
of course Bishop to G4 pinning the
Knight Horvath goes for this move as
it's a very natural move of course you
don't want the Knight to move and now
Bishop to F4 now this is the the the
move that uh made this game possible
it's not not a popular move nowadays H3
and Bishop to E2 are main moves in
Bishop to C4 is sometimes played uh but
if you if if you want to play Bishop to
C4 in a position like this you don't
want to run into a trap like let's say
Knight F6 and then you go Bishop
captures on F7 and you're you know happy
about how how great your uh chess player
you are for example King captures 95
check and now you're gonna win back the
material and then black will just ruin
your day with Queen captures and E5 and
you're gonna have to resign the game
because after a captures captures and
now let's say Knight captures or King
captures doesn't really matter black
will move the Knight and black will be
up a full piece so instead Bishop to F4
was played here and now we have Pawn to
E6 there are a couple of games from 2016
where Knight to F6 was played but here
uh E6 was played and it is now as of
move 6 that the disposition has never
been reached again we have Pawn to H3
challenging the bishop now if the bishop
goes to F5 or H5 you can even challenge
it further with G4 so of course format
captured Queen captures an F3 and the
bishop to B4 putting pressure on that
Knight and now Bishop to E2 and here you
could play really anything you could go
Knight F6 you could go Knight to E7 if
you want a castle King side uh horod
wanted to Castle Queen side so he played
Knight to the D7 and here Esteban uh Set
uh the deadliest of traps he played Pawn
to A3 and if you've seen a lot of
Scandinavian games you you know just how
potent A3 can be in certain situations
and here you have to treat it very
diligently and you should okay obviously
if a capture some B4 Queen captures on
A1 is very good for black and you you
can easily continue with something like
Knight G2 F6 or Knight E7 uh prepare
castles and uh oh you don't have to
worry about a captures on B4 but uh here
uh Mr about played something very very
different he played Queen side castles
it's again a standard moving to
Scandinavian and you want to put a lot
of pressure on this D4 Pawn you already
have the Rook into the game the king is
very safe and it usually works in all
the lines except for this one so feel
free to pause the video and figure out
what is what about missed while I give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
foreign
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding this
beautiful double rook and queen
sacrifice and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is eight
captures on B4 that's the move and now
black can simply resign because black is
down a piece or black can capture The
Rook if he wants to equalize in material
so Queen captures an A1 check was played
and now the only winning move and the
one you had to find in order to play a
capture Sun B4 is not Knight to D1 or
Bishop to D1 or something like that it's
in fact King to D2 and look at this the
queen has no retreat Square on the a
file and also the queen is hanging so
what are you gonna do you can capture on
B2 or you can capture The Rook the
result is absolutely the same so Queen
captures on H1 was played so sacrificing
first stroke sacrifice in the second
rook and now of course sacrificing your
most valuable piece now comes Queen
captures on C6 we can do it like this
nicely in slow motion uh Andy was in
this position on move 13 that uh Mr
Horvath resigned to the game and as
there is nothing more to be done here
once of course the queen is captured you
will see what what happens next after B
captures and C6 Bishop to A6 will be a
phenomenal double bishop checkmate
Bishop A6 and that's it uh so I don't
know I was very happy I Was preparing
for a serious classical game and then
I'm just you know browsing some games
and then I saw this one and I was so
happy I showed it to everyone everyone
really enjoyed it so I thought you might
you guys might enjoy it as well so it's
nothing spectacular you know uh they
played this very nice uh Queen to D5
line this cannot be played uh even today
okay Bishop therefore is a bit rare but
you can play it and then if your
opponent doesn't react well today's A3
move and you already control uh this
diagonal and this diagonal you can just
sacrifice both of your Rooks Captain C6
and deliver a beautiful double bishop
checkmate and you will be well Immortal
forever so uh like uh Esteban Canal is
with this game that is referred to as
the Peruvian Immortal game uh so yeah
that's the game I really hope you guys
enjoyed it for those of you who haven't
seen it I'm sure you are uh well I I
know I've seen it before but now that
you know it randomly popped up uh in my
feed I was so happy so hope I improved
your day as well I would like to thank
goodness
festival.org.gg Amanda Oliver the most
beautiful girl in the world Duncan wine
called egbertian sherhorn and all of
Ollie for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day